[Music]  have you ever wondered what came next  for elsa and rapunzel  life got real and these two became moms  together talk about best friend goals  we are reimagining the stars of frozen  and tangled as modern day mothers  lucky for them it's not just a pregnancy  glow these ladies are rocking  we've given them a glow up to match with  custom jewelry fierce makeup and a blunt  cut for the ice clean  just wait and see  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  what do you think rapunzel and elsa  would be like as modern day parents  do you want to see them with baby girls  or boys sound off in the comments  section  and hit that like button to show your  love for the disney princess squad  thanks for watching  [Music]  you